[Musique]
eh ben ça avance bien tout ça
patrice tiens j'ai attrapé chou
[Musique]
c'est un 8 1 contre à ce moment là d'une
l'ensemble du banc dont l'état sera
également touchée c'est une catastrophe
ou c'est ça qui font quoi va chercher
92000 taux de vitamine c est ça n'a
l'air tout à fait faux bond lui a
maintenant et oui la maintenance entend
enfin il faut sortir les bords de la
route la même pas eu le temps de réviser
le traîneau rouge et le mode furtif en
rade les patins ils sont tous liste et
j'ai un reina plat à la bombe
c'est du suicide est marrant tel un
aller-retour fils touche appel à tous
les régimes
on va se poser là bas après du gros
jouet rouge
top top tap tap tap tap tap tomber lyon
luton
donne-moi 92000 comme ça le lion c'est
le nom klaus prénom sans talent pour
faire un test d'alcoolémie de
stupéfiants
et ça ça va aider pour mes lutins et on
va faire ce stupéfiant dirais quoi moi
je suis votre avocat je suis à poser
pour les vous êtes en prison
oui je sais ce qu'ils nous présentent
même si je fabrique des monopoly donc
donnez-moi dd je fais un double et je
sors non non non non non non est-ce que
tu as la moindre idée de ce qui va se
passer si pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de noël les enfants n'ont pas
joué
[Musique]
si je sauve pas les lutins du rap à noël
je suis le père noël et j'ai déjoué à
livrer
oh
ça me fait réaliser que bas que tout
n'arrive pas magiquement comme ça
qu'il faut se battre aussi pour les gens
qu'on aime c'est le discours miss france
l'année dernière au congo comment dit
bonjour m ont dit non pas du tout là
vous avez dit voiture yourte à la fraise
ou sharapova
oui bah du coup il en veut bien